you know hunter hunter has some of my
favorite protagonists full-time mean you
have gone killowog raka and Hisoka such
a powerhouse for they are actually I
feel like I'm forgetting someone think
his name starts with an L oh wow what is
it it's like they are lose oh no no no
it's more like Leo Leo Leo Leo huh
that's right it's Leo I can't believe I
almost forgot about Leo
but thankfully they all did not forget
to subscribe to the new order view for
regular Hunter hunter content uploaded
straight into his YouTube feed such a
great protagonist Leo Liz hello and
welcome to the new world review your
source for everything anime and manga
and today it's time to address the lay
Oreo in the room and talk about exactly
what has happened to one of our
protagonists in the series because yes
while it may not seem like it
leo is still most certainly one of the
four or five if you can't soca'
protagonists that make up the heart and
soul of hunter hunter however compared
to his peers leo has been handed a bit
of a rough deal they do think that a lot
of this rather unfortunately stems from
the fact that hunter hunter is very
clearly an improvised story from a meta
perspective a lot of work goes into
planning out individual arcs and togar
she is a phenomenal micro narrative
writer but the broader plan was not in
place and what happened is that Takashi
developed a handful of characters a few
broad concepts hit the Go button and
then I imagined he was probably just as
surprised with every twist and turn the
story took as we were and the amazing
thing is that for the most part this has
worked in great favor of hunter hunter
allowing Takashi to follow whatever his
passion of the day is and create an
incredibly compelling story and
characters based around it however this
kind of organic storytelling does also
have its flaws and one of them can be
clearly seen in the character of Leora
but to really get into this let's
examine layer his initial role in the
series because at the inception of
hunter hunter mayoría formed a pillar of
perfect balance amongst the main cast
the initial team of four consisting in
play Oreo gone killer and Karaka was a
tried and tested formula guaranteed to
succeed and I say this because initially
took a she began by producing let's face
it a carbon copy of what will call to
you Hawk Asha formula that was applied
to his fallen mega-hit series of the
same name and yes there are very
distinct personality differences between
the protagonist who view Hawk show and
hunter hunter but archetype Lee speaking
gun is Yusuke Killa why is he a crop
occur is drama and Leigh order was given
the owner with bean Kuwabara did I say
honor quite seriously because what cool
represented in you hakusho was the angry
but charming idiot with a heart of gold
and a character designed to be
universally enjoyed for any number of
those aspects now the primary difference
from a mechanical standpoint between
Kawara and lay audio is that they re Oh
is very much kept out of the combat side
of the series which was a nice
difference actually because it meant
that oh gosh she had to find a new and
interesting way to incorporate lay Oreo
into various situations without him just
conjuring a spirit sword and blasting
his way to victory however what it also
resulted in was they Oreos primary role
amongst main cast being that of comic
relief as well as moral backbone and
during the first two arcs of haunt
hunter they re oh absolutely excelled in
those areas in terms of comic relief
Liara was a godsend amongst a group of
very pure characters like gone or overly
serious and stoic existences like
kilowatt and Karaka but more importantly
I mentioned that Li reo had the task of
being the moral backbone of the group
which can seem like a bit of a joke at
first because on the surface level he
has incredible flaws like being a bit of
a pervert and obsessed with money but
when you think back to the hunter exam
ox pacifically the large majority of
inspiring dramatic beats are given to
lay REO to deliver for example in the
swindle Swamp section where the group
encountered Hisoka and decided to split
up and run now up until this point you
would expect they or her to be the first
wonderfully as well in fact he'd
probably be the person to run fastest
which is what you would expect from a
comic relief character but instead of
running they Oriya returns to face
Hisoka one-on-one without a hope in the
world of victory and he does so due to a
simple personal belief and this is one
of the most powerful moments of the
hunter exam arc in my opinion but we can
also find another one in the final phase
where it would be lay Oreo who
encourages kilowatt not to give in to
ill amis psychological manipulation in
any other shown in series that speech
probably would have been given to the
main character although I guess gone was
out of action by this point however the
idea still stands mayoría was made to be
the heart of this quartet and that is
only further solidified when we
discovered that his motives for wanting
mass quantities of money is that so that
he can become a doctor and treat people
for free and in that moment Lee ro
becomes more pure than any character
introduced thus far and it makes the
other three protagonists look downright
selfish in comparison although I will
say that leras motivation is
unfortunately most certainly a primary
factor in contributing to his
disappearance from the series which I'll
get into in a second but at this stage
it's also very important to highlight
that Lee Oreo as a character can only
function as part of a group dynamic he's
funny and inspiring both heavily
desirable try
but those alone cannot push him further
in a world like this he needs the
strength of characters like gon and
killua as well as the shrewd
intelligence if someone like Korra
packet to progress and actually in the
initial arcs of the series I would argue
that this is the same for the entire
group these four formed a symbiotic
relationship where they effectively
became a super being capable of tackling
any challenge that came their way and in
motion in series and author would be an
absolute fool to disturb that balance
it's kind of like forcibly breaking up
the Beatles and watching them all follow
their solo careers but that is exactly
what Takashi would come to do because
the story he wanted to tell had evolved
from that of a typical shown in battle
manga and after two arcs in the series
this fantastic foursome was broken up
and would never properly be reformed in
this left lair Rio in a very tricky
position he goes out of all of the
characters in this group he was the one
who was really unable to survive in his
own right do both to his lack of power
as well as his primary motivating factor
and to explain the ladder let's first
take a look at say Korra pika when the
band broke up tropica went on to have a
phenomenal solo outing because he was
driven to the core by his desire to
reclaim the eyes of his clan members and
take revenge on the Phantom troupe this
very simple idea is what allowed Takashi
to grant cropper cut the power he needed
to achieve such a thing as well as a
narrative flexibility to put him into a
particularly dramatic story because he
has a clear set of goals and enemies in
contrast aro does not his goal in life
is much more noble he wants to heal
people and the biggest challenge in
regards to that is acquiring the
knowledge and the money to do so
so while Korra pika was vigorously
training lay Arya was rather
understandably vigorously at work
studying medicine and while that is
perfect in terms of a character choice
to make it does have the effect of
making Lee arya very difficult to
incorporate into the story in any
meaningful capacity at least in this
story which was still very battle
focused a REO has no enemy to seek out
nor does he have a reason to seek any
kind of power in fact he goes so far as
to refuse to learn and in order to focus
on his studies which once again is a
perfect character choice to make but it
really does not help him in terms of
making him a primary aspect of the
trauma at hand which from heavens arena
onwards was all centered on nen and you
can't really blame Takashi for this I
mean when he began hunter hunter he may
have had vague ideas about nen but he
almost certainly had no clear vision on
how it would be implemented and how this
group of characters would go about
applying it to their own individual
desires fitly REO is very much a victim
of this lack of planning
if you will and one that took our she
did try to use as best he could in your
q city but it just wasn't anywhere near
the same as his relevance to the hunter
exam and zoldak family arcs and then of
course the darkest period for lay oreo
would be upon us as after the conclusion
of york new city we went immediately
into the back-to-back eternity that is
greed island followed by the chimera and
talk and lay oreo had absolutely no
place in either of these once again do
almost exclusively to his core
motivation but here's the thing you
could make an argument that lay oreo
would have been useful less so during
creed island i guess but in regards to
the chimera and sure why not if
characters like you can't go and merely
i wrong complain integral role in the
palace invasion then why can't lawyer
and once again it comes back to simply
because he was not developed enough in
terms of nen if lay oreo had immediately
trained like the rest of the protagonist
and by the chimera antic he could have
developed his own unique utility han-soo
like male iran's called to compass for
example i mean layer i still would not
have been a part of the main action that
he would have had a function on the team
which is how this character is best
utilized but with no nan and no profound
desire to learn it then there was
nothing that could have been done he was
for all intents and purposes a regular
old human and by this time hunter hunter
had long evolved to a point where
regular humans had no place in current
events i mean even when you think of
comedy she is no regular human and now
that isn't to say that lay aria would
never have his time to shine again as
during the 13th hunter chairman election
arc he had you know a decent grasp on
men but even then lay oreo was used as
an auxiliary factor with jing
manipulating the greatest situation
surrounding him and to be fair that was
completely fine
having lee oreo run for chairman was
both hilarious and compelling because at
this point I had really missed his
character and it was the first time
since the zelda [ __ ] that his full
potential in the series had even come
close to being realized but even then it
doesn't quite get there gone was out of
action crop occur was nowhere to be seen
and kill allah had his own task at hand
so there was no one for layer arrow to
bounce off and that is very important
because that dream team scenario where
he slots perfectly into that formula
does still exist if these four were to
ever reunite they Oreo would be a
perfectly fine addition to the team
almost integral I would say however it's
practically guaranteed that this is
never going to happen so where does that
leave Lee Oreo in the modern day well
lay Oreo is still somewhat involved in
the story as a member of the zodiacs no
less which is nice very
I love that he's a bullet the black
whale one and in the thick of all the
succession well business but even then
he's still only going to be a feature on
the outskirts but the princes the
Phantom troop ahsoka Cora pika
Allah me and everything else happening
on the ship Lee REO is once again
completely outclassed and it's going to
be very difficult to give him the same
kind of dramatic oomph that he was once
able to command but even with all of us
in mind there is still one bit of hope a
teeny tiny bit but it's there and this
brings up because after the succession
war hunter hunter is more than likely
going to need a new key protagonist to
follow and I say this because kropog a
story threads are all completely tied up
in this war the last of the scarlet I is
the Phantom troop the ever
self-sacrificing Emperor time it's all
there we've got a video on it if you
want to watch it but once we get to the
Dark Continent I think that he is going
to be out of the picture at which point
someone needs to take that place now
there are other prime candidates such as
Jing well maybe even bringing back on or
kill her but those last two are a very
maybe situation so the Dark Continent
may actually be set up as a chance for
lai REO to truly shine because it's not
as if he has no drive to be there the
Dark Continent has all sorts of crazy
benefits for Humanity like a herb that
can cure thousands of diseases so it's
not impossible although it is highly
unlikely in the end once again I keep
coming back to this but he is just not
proficient enough to be the center of
attention at this stage in the story
however part of me does really enjoy the
theoretical contrast that he would
provide if he did helm in Dark Continent
arc
I mean just imagine this quite possibly
the weakest end user to potentially set
foot on this land going up against the
most terrifying threats that we have
ever faced in hunter hunter and then
watching layer L overcome those feats in
his own unique way because that's the
thing it's very easy to get caught up in
strength and power as even I have in
this video but hunter hunter has never
really been about that even at the very
top levels of combat because you know
you can have an existence like Mara web
who is supremely dominant over everyone
and everything but then you can also
have an existence like Kaimuki who comes
along and just trounces him at gungi you
can never quite tell how two beings will
interact and if toga she really wanted
to I think that presents a huge amount
of potential within the OREA but of
course Takashi has never really wanted
to use the area like that in the
entirety of hunter hunter so once again
it does become a bit difficult to see
him starting now it's far more likely
that he will continue to be
get into the background for the
remainder of the series regardless I
will always remember early lair air
fondly and continue to enjoy his rare
yet hilarious and often touching
appearances in Hunter hunter but what do
you guys think would you like to see you
Larry are back in the spotlight feel
free to comment with your answer down
below and if you came for more Hunter
hunter content then please do check out
some of my other videos and even
subscribe to the channel for regular
Hunter hunter glory uploaded straight
into YouTube feeds this has been the new
world review and I'll see you next time